With more than 300,000 species of plants on the ground, there is no doubt that they have a high degree of sophistication
It senses survival and growth. But while some of its features can be compared in
Taste, sight, touch and smell, including humans, have you ever wondered - can plants think?
On the ground, the cumulative total of plants is 1000 times higher than the animals. But
These plants are unable to move, and can not move around their environment which is, apparently,
This is one of the disadvantages of evolution. This forced the plants to adapt in amazing ways
Which often pass unnoticed before the naked eye.
Do you smell bad? Plants also smell it - and react with these chemicals in the air.
For example, when the fruits begin to ripen, they release a chemical called ethylene. And when
The nearby fruit senses this pheromone, ripens faster, so that all fruits can mature
At the same time. Plants also release some odors that attract insects to spread pollen.
Especially the amazing jiffy flowers they develop delicate bristles, warm and have a smell like
Rotting the body in an attempt to imitate the dead body. Leading to attracting flies and beetles
As pollinators.
On the other hand, when the propellant is attacked by an insect, animal or disease, it is known.
When animals feed on acacia trees, they are quickly returned by producing chemicals called
Tannins, which make their leaves unpalatable and difficult to digest. Some even produce enough
Of poison to kill the animal. Perhaps more impressive is what some of the corn and cotton plants do, which when done
Eaten by caterpillars, excreted chemicals in the air attracts parasitic wasps, who
Flyers intervene in the position and eventually kill insects at a certain level, they continue with wasps.
As much as this seems crazy, even sound recordings of caterpillars chew the leaves, triggering the plants
Even without any form of touch, the plants show a reaction, as if they can hear.
On a large scale, plants also work together. A network of underground fungi can reach the roots of trees
In the forests, allowing them to exchange food and information. Using isotopes
Radioactive, scientists have discovered that trees share water and nutrients with other trees in need
Large shaded trees feed the smaller ones until they become tall enough to reach the sun, and
Trees that remain green throughout the year are involved with food trees that lose their leaves
In the winter - to help them during this season. And then these trees repay their religion in the summer months,
Such as transaction exchange. Some scientists describe this as "a vast network of wood."
Perhaps the most shocking fact is that some plants have a memory
, Are those leafy plants that close when touched. This reaction is intended to intimidate
Insects do not even land on them. In an experiment on these reactions, scientists have observed that
When it drops from a height of 15cm it closes what the group hits. This is not surprising. But
After repeated dropping them 4 or 5 times, some of the plants stop shutting, as if they are
I realized that this incentive was not harmful. If it is shaken instead, it closes,
But at any time dropped from the same height, they remain open. This effect continued
For weeks - plants have memories.
Of course, plants do not have brains or other cells and devices that we consider necessary to
For intelligence. The brains and neurons are irreplaceable, but the plants are unable to move, and often attack,
Therefore you must be able to survive after you devour or destroy part of it. Brain only
Will not work. But if you measure intelligence or think that it is the ability to solve problems,
Interact with the environment, even work in groups, if the plants are incredibly intelligent.
It's something to think about next time you chew a piece of cauliflower!
And if you need any more convincing that the plants actually, amazing - check out our new section at
AsapTHOUGHT channel, where we share some of the facts of your favorite plants. Link in
the description!
Thanks audible.com for giving you a free audio book of your choice at audible.com/asap.
Is the leading provider of audio books with over 150,000 titles for download via
All types of literature.
Check out "Monkey Journey" which suggests some new theories on how to plant and animal
Arrived as it is today. You can download this audio book or another of your choice
Free at audible.com/asap. Then use the free application to listen on Apple
Windows or Android device. Special thanks to audible for making these videos possible
And offers you a free audio book of your choice at audible.com/asap.
And to get more weekly science videos.